Hello. Welcome everyone. It is February
25th, 2026. We are in Active Inference
guest stream 15.4 with Bobby Azarian and
guests Kevin Schmidt and Karl Friston.
Looking forward to this presentation and
discussion. Bobby will present some
slides and then we will have a panel
discussion and I'll read some live
chats. So, thank you to Bobby and guests
for joining and please take it away,
Bobby.
Friston Institute. I love talking to you
because this can be
technical and accessible at the same
time, which I think it really needs to
be for this topic.
And thank you to Kevin and Karl for
attending. If you guys have any
questions or comments, just feel free to
jump in.
There are about 60 slides, so I'm going
to try to keep this to under an hour.
So, I'm going to be going through slides
pretty quickly.
And
we will not get to some of the stuff
that I wanted to about how this informs
AI, but we'll touch on that at the end,
but we're going to focus on one of the
greatest mysteries of science,
the mystery of consciousness.
It's It's one of
the the great remaining mysteries of
science.
Um
So, the framework that we're going to
use to try to answer this mystery is
called strange loop theory.
And I named it that after Douglas
Hofstadter's strange loop idea that he
wrote about in his
Pulitzer Prize winning book Gödel,
Escher, Bach and again in the follow-up
I Am a Strange Loop. Bringing that idea
together with
major neuroscience theories and
consciousness theories, specifically
Karl's free energy principle and
Tononi's integrated information theory.
So,
yeah, let's begin.
So, Richard Feynman
had this famous statement, "What I
cannot create, I do not understand."
More commonly spoken as if if you if you
can't build it, you don't understand it.
So, this was written on the blackboard
during the time of his death and will
serve as a kind of theme for this talk.
So, the converse is also true. If we can
build it,
then we understand it, at least to some
degree. So, building a conscious machine
would be the ultimate test
of any theory of consciousness. Maybe
the term machine isn't perfect because,
for example, if we create AI on
self-organized neuromorphic hardware,
for example, there are these silver
nanowire networks that
self-organized
and
do we call that a machine? It's more
like life. Let's Let's say building a
conscious AI system is the ultimate test
of any theory of consciousness.
And let's call that Feynman's challenge.
We claim to understand consciousness.
I I think we
That's That's the the big claim of this
talk is that we understand the
mechanisms enough to say that in theory
we understand what gives rise to
consciousness and
we want to prove that ultimately by
building a a conscious system.
So,
um
what this presentation offers, a
mechanistic explanation of how
consciousness arises from physical
processes. It's also going to briefly
give a cosmic explanation for why
consciousness exists, which is more of a
philosophical and
existential claim.
And we will briefly touch on an
an engineering path to prove our model
by designing
a conscious system.
So, we start with the infinite infamous
hard problem. David Chalmers defined
this problem explicitly in 1995, but
it's a it's a problem that's really
centuries old. It's kind of a
restatement of the mind-body problem.
So, what is consciousness and why does
it exist? Before we can
explain consciousness, we need to define
it. That's always been a tricky issue
because
for example, you can have an AI system
an LLM that responds as if it's
conscious, but we have no good reason to
believe that these systems actually have
phenomenal experience. So, it gets real
tricky when you're trying to give a
scientific description or definition of
consciousness. The philosopher Thomas
Nagel
um posed a solution just to basically
defining consciousness as something it
is like
to be
a conscious entity. So, an organism that
has conscious an organism has conscious
mental states if and only if
there's something it is like to be that
organism. He has a famous essay, "What
Is It Like to Be a understand anything,
it's best to understand its opposite, to
to compare it to something else. Um
So, when David Chalmers outlined the
hard problem, he also outlined
the easy problem. And the easy problem,
which isn't easy at all, it's extremely
hard, but
it seemed tractable because in the '90s,
functional
MRI was getting popular and these new
neuroimaging tools were being used in
conjunction with cognitive psychology
measures and we were basically, you
know, understanding the cognitive
mechanisms associated with
consciousness. So, the easy problem is a
series of problems that include
understanding perception, so how we
discriminate and categorize stimuli,
attention, so what we attend to is what
we're conscious of. So, to understand
consciousness, we really need to
understand how attention works.
Integration,
how we bind sensory processing
streams. There's this famous binding
problem.
How how is our visual and our auditory
streams
of information
bound together into a coherent whole?
And the difference between sleep and
awake states and states under
anesthesia. So, consciousness is
something that emerges when we're awake
and then leaves. So,
there's something There's a phenomenon
there that needs to be explained.
The hard problem
is not about those cognitive mechanisms.
It's about why is physical information
processing why
does it have a feeling? Why is there
subjective experience accompanying this
cognition? So, we know our computers do
complex information processing tasks,
but we don't think that
our computers
that there's anything it's like to be
our computer. So, there seems to be this
explanatory gap. How do we get from
mechanism to experience? And that That's
really the hard problem. It's the
mystery of subjective experience.
So, I think we have things backwards. I
think the hard problem is the easy
problem, not not necessarily easy, but
the easier problem.
You can answer the hard problem with a
theoretical
explanation, where the easy problem is
this set
you know, it's a technical problem where
we have to understand the nuts and bolts
of the cognitive processes that are
associated with consciousness.
So, I think the easy problem um
will still remain a problem
after the hard problem is pretty much
solved. And actually, by the end of this
talk, we can maybe see that this
distinction is kind of meaningless, that
there's just one problem and that when
you understand the hard problem, uh
it becomes an additional problem on top
of the other
easy problem. So, we need to understand
perception, attention, integration, and
also
world and self-modeling. And when we add
self-modeling to that list of easy
problems, then we start to get at the
mechanism underlying the generation of
conscious experience.
So,
um
once we explain how a self emerges
through mechanism and understand what
qualia are in these terms, what remains
is a challenge, not a problem. So, it's
kind of an optimistic spin on this. So,
today the goal is to convert the hard
problem into a hard challenge and that's
um
what we call the super hard problem. So,
how can we create a conscious system
from scratch? This requires solving both
the hard and easy problems sufficient to
reproduce the phenomenon. So, this is
Feynman's challenge applied to
consciousness.
And the claim is that strange loop
theory converts the hard problem into an
engineering specification. Build a
system with an integrated model of the
world and then have that system model
itself modeling the world.
So, uh
if we want to address this problem, we
should talk about the philosophical
landscape, the different existing
positions on consciousness so we can see
what they get right and what they
potentially get wrong.
Um and when we talk about these
different stances on consciousness,
we're going to be talking about
philosophies like materialism, idealism,
dualism, panpsychism.
Um these uh are stances that address
what could be called the hard problem of
reality. So, so what's the nature of
existence? Is it all physical? Is it all
mental?
Is it a combination of the two? If so,
how do those things interact? So, to
solve one, we must solve the other, it
seems.
So, dualism, uh that was the early
stance, uh famous one, uh by Descartes,
uh who had the famous statement, uh I
think, therefore I am.
So, Descartes uh basically said that
reality consists of two distinct
substances. There's this material stuff
and then there's this mental stuff.
Um and somehow minds influence matter,
but he didn't really explain how this uh
influence happens, which leads to a a
ghost in the machine problem where you
have something that is seemingly
immaterial pushing material stuff around
and that seems to violate the
mechanistic worldview of science, the
Newtonian worldview.
Um Descartes was a Christian, so he
equated consciousness with the soul, and
for that reason, dualism has pretty much
um
uh fallen out of popularity with modern
um scientists and philosophers, except
in a weaker form, which is called
property dualism, and this says there's
only one substance, but some systems can
have non-physical properties like
consciousness, which have genuine causal
power over their material components.
And so, uh Chalmers himself and Christof
Koch are sympathetic to this stance,
and uh there may be nothing wrong with
this stance. This may, you know,
basically it's saying that the mental
emerges from the material and it also
has causal power. So, um
like the other ones we're going to see,
when someone asks, is dualism right, you
have to ask what you mean by dualism
exactly.
So, materialism,
um
pretty much replaced uh
dualism in academia in the 19th and 20th
centuries.
Uh this was called eliminative
reductionism,
um because scientists had this physical
and mechanistic worldview,
uh
they weren't sure how to handle
consciousness and subjective experience.
So, the the the sort of
move, the chess move they made was to
completely um
ignore consciousness or say that
consciousness doesn't exist in the sense
that we think it does, and that kind of
magically got rid of the problem. So,
that was called eliminative eliminative
reductionism.
It was popular with um the Churchlands.
Um this led to the illusionist position
that just said it out right that
consciousness isn't real, it's an
illusion,
um made popular by people like Daniel
Dennett and Keith Frankish, and
basically says consciousness emerges
from neural activity, but phenomenal
experience is a cognitive mirage. So,
this kind of just evaporates the hard
problem, but the paradox is they're
saying it's an emergent property, but
that it doesn't exist at the same time.
So, which one is it? Illusionists live
life as if consciousness is real and has
causal power, so it's
you you're kind of like a walking
contradiction. If you're an illusionist,
um and you can't get away from this uh
simple cogito ergo sum statement of
Descartes, I think, therefore I exist,
so denying the subjective means denying
the reality of the map you're navigating
with.
Um
Dan Dennett's book, Consciousness
Explained, is jokingly called
Consciousness Ignored by uh
consciousness researchers because uh
rather than addressing the issue of
experience head-on, it just kind of
dodges it. And John Searle said that
when it comes to consciousness, the
illusion is the reality. So, we know
consciousness, we know the map is not
the territory, it's
uh virtual construction, and Anil Seth
calls it a hallucination, but that's
something. Calling it not real, saying
it doesn't exist, doesn't make sense
because the
virtual simulation, that that model,
that's something itself. So, you can't
really say it's an illusion. An illusion
to who? The the the statement itself um
suggests uh
an agent of experience.
So, there's also idealism, which says
everything emerges from consciousness,
the mind creates reality. The problem
with uh
what you could call naive idealism is
that things exist that no one has
observed. If if an astronaut
goes to another planet and
uh
doesn't see a rock
in his in his path and trips on that, he
he trips on something real that's never
been observed by anyone. So, the idea
that the mind is creating reality has a
fundamental flaw unless
uh you are talking about a form of
idealism like analytic idealism, um
which basically says that the the
material world emerges from this uh
consciousness that's a universal
consciousness. That's a very different
um argument, and so is idealism right or
wrong? Well, it depends on what version
you're talking about. Um this framework
would say that fundamentally
uh the universe is uh an information
processing systems. So, if you see mind
as information processing, then
uh yes, mind is fundamental in that
sense,
um but if you're defining mind as what
it's like to be something, then it seems
that mind emerges with life and
probably, you know, robustly with
with brains, not until brains. Um
panpsychism is a similar idea. It
doesn't try to explain away the
material, it just says that um
the material world has this conscious
aspect to it, and that
everything, whether you're talking
about, you know, atoms or chairs or the
universe as a whole, is conscious.
Again, if you're talking about
information processing, then one could
make the claim that the universe is
conscious in that it's processing
information, but if you're defining
consciousness like Nagel, what it's like
to be something, um then I don't think
panpsychism is right. I don't think
atoms, I don't think there's anything
it's like to be an atom or a chair.
Um
but this framework, so one could call it
a sort of emergent panpsychism, that
that consciousness inevitably emerges in
the universe and spreads as life spreads
outwards. So, um
the last position that I'll mention is
mysterianism,
uh made popular in the '90s by the
philosopher Colin McGinn. Um
neuroscientist Eric Hall um holds this
position now in a kind of new version, a
kind of Gödelian version that's
interesting. Um just as a dog cannot
comprehend quantum mechanics, uh
humans may lack the conceptual apparatus
to solve the hard problem. Um and Eric
says consciousness may be fundamentally
undecidable,
like a Gödel sentence.
Um our response is that Gödelian
slipperiness isn't a roadblock, but the
engine of discovery.
Um understanding consciousness does
change the configuration of the
conscious system comprehending itself,
producing something emergent, something
new to understand.
Um so,
yeah, in some way, the the mystery of
consciousness will go on forever because
of this.
Um understanding consciousness will
create new configurations in reality
that need to be understood. So, it's
kind of this um Gödelian
uh problem that that that you have to
create these meta-frameworks for,
um but this creates an infinite ladder
of understanding that drives scientific
progress and knowledge creation.
So, the mystery of consciousness
um is really uh an engine of progress.
Um and so, uh when we're done with the
framework, we'll see how each position
represents a partial truth,
um and when the mysteries unravel, they
will be seen as complementary rather
than contradictory.
And so, we will talk about a a third
hard problem in addition to the hard
problem of consciousness and the hard
problem of reality.
There's the practical hard problem that
we're all dealing with every day. Uh we
can call this the hard problem of
survival.
Um so, this problem's not philosophical
like the others, but practical, yet it
provides the solution that solves all
our hard problems. The key is
understanding why minds exist in the
first place, and that's to aid survival,
to aid persistence.
So,
uh
minds uh uh exist um
for a basic thermodynamic reason, for a
thermodynamic imperative.
So, this is
become famous uh
to scientists, this uh saying. I don't
think it's known enough,
but the saying is the second law of
thermodynamics is the first law of
psychology.
Um that was made explicit in a paper in
2003.
So, this idea is our mental processes
function to help us resist entropy's
pull. Minds are required for persistence
to acquire energy and avoid threats,
which is what we need to do to persist.
We must model the world. And this is uh
pretty much what the free energy
principle uh and the Bayesian brain
process are are based on. This is how
they frame it. Um to resist entropy, uh
agents have to create uh predictive
models.
So, this is an old idea. Goes back all
the way to Erwin Schrödinger,
uh famous physicist, uh wrote a great
book in 1944, What is Life? Actually
based on a lecture. So, everyone should
check that out if they don't know it. It
says, "Living systems seem to defy the
disordering tendency associated with the
second law. Life creates and maintains
islands of remarkable organization not
by violating physics, but by extracting
energy from the environment." So, to
stay ordered, you have to get energy. To
get energy, you have to build a model of
the world.
And Dennett said in 1995, "What then are
living things? They are things that defy
this crumbling into dust at least for a
while by not being isolated, by taking
in from their environment the
wherewithal to keep life and limb
together." So, you see this recurring
theme
in popular science books. In 2017,
Steven Pinker wrote, "The second law
defines the ultimate purpose of life,
mind and human striving, to deploy
energy and information to fight back the
tide of entropy and carve out refuges of
beneficial order." So, we can really
understand purpose and agency through
this window. Uh agency uh is basically
um
this uh struggle to maintain persistence
in a world that tends toward entropic
decay. So, Anil Seth more recently says,
"I have to actively resist the second
law of thermodynamics so I don't
dissipate into all kinds of states. I
don't just dissolve into mush on the
floor. It's an active process."
And so, this is tied to biological
agency, but also intimately tied to
consciousness itself. Uh in that
article, uh Anil argues that
consciousness may be nature's way of
allowing its intelligent creations to
keep going
to almost always find a way.
So,
uh
to to to this kind of summarizes how we
get from uh
entropy to experience. So, this is
this is the narrative. The second law
creates this pressure um systems
uh have to resist
dissolution. And to do that, uh requires
finding energy and anticipating threats.
So, navigation and anticipation requires
predictive modeling.
You have to build a map of the world to
be able to get around in it.
And prediction requires simulating
counterfactuals.
So, the argument is that consciousness
is this simulation. It's the virtual
world the system runs to select actions.
So, your your brain is a computational
system
running a world model. But where does
the self come from? The I in I think,
therefore I am. It's not just enough to
have
a world model. The simulation becomes
conscious when the simulator appears
inside its own simulation. This is the
strange loop.
So, on to the next part, uh you are a
strange loop, how self-modeling creates
the self.
So, the argument is that there are two
requirements for consciousness. First, a
system that builds a world model to
navigate entropic challenges. Second, a
recursive leap where that system
incorporates itself into its own model.
When a model begins modeling itself
modeling the world, pretty loopy, uh
something remarkable happens. A
self-referential loop generates a
perspective, advantage point, an I. So,
that was the real mystery. Um
and the concept of a simulation doesn't
quite get you there because our computer
simulations, they there's there's
nothing it is like to be those
simulations. So, we need something more,
and that's self-modeling.
Um
So, Douglas Hofstadter, uh
you know, this isn't a new idea. This
goes back to 1979, and he really
described it in detail. Um
and so, he he calls the strange loop. He
describes it as a level crossing
information pathway that folds in on
itself, something like a mental Möbius
strip.
So, the idea is that without
self-modeling, the generative model is a
Cartesian theater with no one in the
audience.
Um so, the world simulation is not
sufficient. It must place the simulator
within the simulated world.
And we get a picture of reality being
relational from this.
Uh so, Hofstadter um has this cool
little demonstration he likes to
mention. Think of what happens when a TV
camera is pointed uh at the screen so as
to display the screen on itself, a
self-engulfing television. When and only
when such a loop arises uh in a brain or
any other substrate is a person, a
unique I brought into being.
And here's a picture of this strange
loop. So, this is a camera pointed at a
monitor, and you see this emergent uh
fractal structure. Uh Hofstadter claims
that the the self, the I, um emerges in
an analogous way.
And
so, um
how does the self model emerge? Um
unlike uh organisms that just have uh
genes, organisms with brains are able to
record the consequences of the
organism's actions in real time. So, so
you need brains to be able to map the
immediate causal consequences of your
actions. And when you're doing that,
then you're building up a model of the
self.
Um so, that builds up uh a model of your
behavioral routines and patterns. And
this generative model transforms into an
experiential subject when that happens.
Um so, the phenomenological world
emerges from uh recursive processing.
And this doesn't just explain emergence
of consciousness, uh it explains the
emergence of levels of consciousness.
So, self-consciousness emerges um from
uh
an even higher level of recursive
processing.
And the strange loop spawns a new level
of control. So, it's not just that
you're getting these higher levels of
awareness with richer recursive
processing, the system is also gaining
more autonomy, more causal power of the
world over the world. It's not this
input-output machine any longer. It can
understand its own coding, and it can
modify itself.
So, you have these different levels. So,
the first level, the system models the
world. You just get agentic behavior. Um
probably uh
a sort of zombie system with no um
subjective experience. When the system
models itself modeling the world with
brains, we get consciousness.
When the system models itself
self-modeling, you get
self-consciousness. And a higher level
emerges when the system models itself
within a larger system of agents.
Um at this higher point of reflection,
um that gives rise to
metacognition and all of the uh great
functions that we uh
have thanks to our
um evolved prefrontal cortex.
So, each level adds a new level of
top-down control. It's it's it's really
enabling greater levels of agency.
So, the more self-referentially rich the
loop, the more conscious the self. So,
we're going to talk about integrated
information theory later, and the idea
is that
uh integrated information is necessary
but not sufficient. You have to have
this uh self-reference.
So, Judea Pearl, uh who's been really
influential on AI with his uh work in
Bayesian networks and causal modeling,
uh says, uh "That's consciousness. You
have a model of yourself. Where do you
get this model? You look at yourself as
if you're part of the environment. I
have a blueprint of myself. So, at that
level, I can modify things.
This is what we mean by free will." So,
he connects consciousness to
self-modeling, but he also connects it
to higher agency. That was on the Lex
Fridman podcast.
Um and Carl wrote a wonderful essay for
uh Eon. Uh I recommend that everyone
reads that because it ties all these
together ideas together seamlessly. Uh
he says, "Anytime there's a deviation
from the attractor, this triggers flows
of thoughts, feelings, and movements
that eventually take you back to your
cycle of attracting familiar states.
This view In this view, humans are
little more than strange loops, as
Douglas Hofstadter puts it." So, this is
getting at more than just the
um
the self-modeling loop. We are
cybernetic controllers at a fundamental
level. We use feedback loops to sustain
ourselves
uh against this tide of entropic decay.
And this, you can see he mentions
feelings here.
So this gives us a new perspective on
qualia. Uh qualia is not uh
epiphenomenal.
Uh qualitative experiences are actually
uh adaptive instructions. So they serve
uh to guide the conscious system towards
um
a stable state. So it to guide the
conscious system towards a far from
equilibrium state of dynamic
equilibrium. I guess you could call it a
non-equilibrium equilibrium.
Uh basically an organism tries to
maintain itself in this attractor and a
dynamical attractor uh is applied to
life as a state of homeostatic balance.
So what is pain in this model? It's a
high free energy signal indicating
dangerous deviation.
And so that's why when you touch a hot
stove, you um pull your hand back
quickly. It triggers withdrawal
instructions.
Where pleasant sensations are low free
energy signals and uh
um basically signal the organism to
maintain adaptive behaviors. Of course,
this can be deceptive when we get into
uh you know, can lead to addiction, but
that's uh the point of it. It's it's
basically um
um
a signal to keep uh
dynamic equilibrium against this
tendency to
uh dissolve. So qualia are not
epiphenomenal as the illusionist
position maintains. They have a causal
function.
And so now that we have an understanding
of how the subjective perspective
emerges from self-modeling and the
function of qualia, let's talk about um
how we can potentially
uh quantify
uh consciousness, um which is what
integrated information theory tries to
do with their measure phi. And the
argument here is that consciousness
grows richer with cognitive complexity.
Specifically with the number of
accessible states
the system can access. So
this idea is called repertoire entropy.
We're talking about the
uh number of states a system can
experience. So
the average number of states the typical
human could experience is far richer
than the average number of states of a
of a cat, which is far richer than the
average number of states accessible to
uh
a mouse. Um
so this idea is based on the law of
requisite variety. So the great
cyberneticist Ross Ashby um
wrote this paper in the '50s. The law
says to survive an organism must have a
repertoire of cognitive states and
behavioral responses as large as the
number of different challenges presented
by its environment. So a cat hunting
mice must have as many responses as the
ways the mouse can evade it. A swordsman
must have as many blocks as opponent has
attacks.
And humans who live in a complex social
and technological world, um we require
uh an even greater repertoire of
responses. So the more options a system
has to respond, the more effectively it
can control its situation.
So this thing that we're saying
correlates with degree of consciousness
has an adaptive function. Um more states
means uh
greater ability to control an
unpredictable world. So Francis
Heylighen says, "Since the variety of
perturbations a system can potentially
be confronted with is unlimited, we
should always try to maximize its
internal variety so as to be optimally
prepared for any foreseeable or
unforeseeable contingency."
Um
this idea is uh
popping up in different places. Um From
computational neuroscience to
um physics to AI. So Alex Wissner-Gross
at Harvard says
um has this concept of causal entropic
forcing. Um which says that there's this
drive to maximize future freedom of
action.
So life is trying to increase options.
It's trying to avoid trap states.
Uh Daniel Polani, computational
neuroscientist, uh has this concept of
empowerment.
Which is an agent's capacity to
influence its future states. His
co-author says empowerment means in a
state where you have the greatest
potential influence. So very similar to
causal entropic forcing.
Um and empowerment is proportional to
requisite variety. Um why is this all
relevant to consciousness? The size of
the mental repertoire
relates directly to the richness of
experience. And we're going to explain
why.
Um
so it's worth quickly mentioning the Red
Queen principle as a principle from
evolutionary theory that says that as
competitors evolve, organisms must
expand their repertoire to stay viable.
So this fuels evolutionary arms races,
which act as complexity ratchets. What
begins as simple molecular memory in
genomes eventually evolves into internal
representations in self-aware social
agents. So because of the need um to
complexify
uh life is always generating new species
that have um greater requisite variety.
And because the social world of modern
humans keeps growing more complex,
uh evolution seems to be progressive.
There's always a new niche for
intelligence willing to take on more
complexity.
Kristof Koch, uh one of the famous
proponents of IIT, says the more complex
the system, the larger the repertoire of
conscious states it can experience. So
this isn't some new obscure argument. Uh
this has been echoed by the leaders in
the field. Robin Carhartt-Harris, a
psychedelics researcher, uh has the
entropic brain hypothesis. And he says
the view taken here is that the human
brain exhibits greater entropy than
other members of the animal kingdom,
which is equivalent to saying the human
mind possesses a greater repertoire of
potential mental states than lower
animals.
So what does this mean? It means we can
potentially measure the information
content of a given observation
and we can basically infer that
um
observation
uh
basically works in this
uh same way as observing um
an outcome with like uh
a roll of of dice, for example.
Um so
when you
uh toss a coin and you observe the
outcome, you get one bit of information.
Uh when you observe a six-sided die toss
outcome, you get 2.6 bits of
information. So the amount of
information
um scales with the number of
possibilities.
And so that's a basic way um that's a
basic principle from Claude Shannon's
information theory. And so applying that
to consciousness, we are saying that the
more possible states a cognitive system
can be in, the higher the repertoire
entropy.
So here entropy is not measuring
disorder, but cognitive bandwidth.
Information is a reduction in
uncertainty. So the amount of
information in a signal is the
uncertainty reduced upon observation.
So that leads to the conclusion that the
depth of a conscious moment scales with
the number of states that could be
experienced, but are not currently
actualized. Repertoire entropy measures
this richness. The greater the space of
possibilities, the more information in
an experience.
So the current experience would be
defined by the counterfactual cloud that
surrounds it. Red's redness emerges from
its position within contrast networks,
relationships to green, blue, yellow,
and the entire perceivable spectrum.
And so we can imagine the simplest
organism, for example, a bacterium
performing chemotaxis. It basically only
has two states. If it senses chemical
food, it doesn't move. It doesn't do
anything. And then it basically sits and
feeds on that food. If it doesn't sense
food, it wiggles its tail and that moves
it uh to some new location until it
senses food. So you can imagine a system
with just two states where each state is
defined only by not being the other. So
to understand this new picture, there's
there's this kind of dialectical
relationship between presence and
absence. So this binary agent uh
wouldn't be able to perceive color. The
two states couldn't be um red and blue,
for example.
Um
that the complexity of the experience of
color has to emerge from this network of
relationships.
Uh a system that can only experience two
states would only experience something
like light and dark. And it might even
be misleading to talk about a visual
modality because you don't have the
complexity for for different sensory
streams. It's really just presence or
absence. So if a
sentient being were combined confined to
a binary repertoire or a very small um
number of accessible states, then
it wouldn't be able to have qualia in
any meaningful sense. So it's the
spectrum of possible experiences we
could have, but aren't having that makes
the present what it is. The more
accessible states, the greater the
variety of qualia.
So, as we evolve and learn more and our
spectrum of possible experience
increases, so should the intensity with
with with with which we feel them. The
information content of a conscious
experience increases in proportion to
the size of our mental repertoire. So,
that's pretty interesting. It means as
we learn and as we
go through life and travel to different
destinations, we're basically unlocking
more accessible states. We're increasing
the size of our
um cognitive repertoire, our requisite
variety.
And this makes me think differently
about everything. Like when when I'm
trying like new food, I'm I'm seeing
that as
unlocking like new qualia and new
states. And by doing that and expanding
the size of my
uh
cognitive repertoire, um
I should be increasing the richness of
each conscious experience because each
observation will then be rolling out all
of the experiences that I could have had
but aren't having at that moment. So,
it's it's it's a practical philosophy as
well.
Uh repertoire entropy measures the
number of adaptive responses available.
So, the requisite variety, this has been
estimated in a paper by uh cognitive
scientist named Danko Nikolic. Um so,
you can actually uh kind of uh calculate
exact um
uh repertoire entropy figures for
different species based on what we know.
Um integrated information theory's phi,
uh
touted as a measure for consciousness,
um already captures this. Uh phi is
measuring the degree to which a system
is more than the sum of its parts. So,
it's measuring emergence. Uh to
calculate phi, you have to calculate uh
the repertoire entropy. It's it's
implicit in that calculation. And phi is
constrained by repertoire size. So, the
larger the repertoire, the larger the
potential phi. So, the conclusion is phi
is a good proxy measure for
consciousness because it captures
repertoire entropy, but it should be
emphasized that integrated information
is necessary but not sufficient in this
framework.
Uh so, strange loop theory says
consciousness requires self-modeling in
addition to integrated information.
So, how does this new framework uh
resolve old paradoxes? So, we're going
to just focus on two.
Um but really, this framework seems to
dissolve uh all of the major um
philosophy of mind paradoxes that have
you know, any any book on consciousness
you read will will go through these and
I think it it addresses these pretty
nicely. Um so, there's this famous uh
zombie problem that that that Chalmers
and Dennett
uh
talked about and really made famous. But
the idea is that you can imagine
um
a being or a system physically identical
to you but with no inner experience. So,
it behaves exactly like you. It talks,
responds, claims to be a conscious, but
there's nothing it's like to be that
thing. All of the information processing
is happening in the dark, the way our
computer processes information, but we
don't believe it has a subjective
perspective. You could imagine the
zombie that looks like you that's not
having that experience. And Chal-
Chalmers argues that if zombies are
conceivable,
consciousness can't be physical, that it
must transcend the physical.
Um so, this has been used to argue for
dualism for decades.
So, how does this framework handle it?
It's
It's really interesting because it says
this zombie idea, it's kind of
misguided, but it's actually super
important to understanding
um
uh like our current AI systems. So, you
could embody an LLM like ChatGPT in a
robot that looks like you,
and it could have similar
um behavior, and it could report all of
these things, but just just the way we
interact with LLMs and sometimes they'll
report being conscious um or having
experiences.
Um you could build a robot, an embodied
LLM,
um that's an actual zombie. So,
according to this theory,
uh and it's really pulling from
integrated information theory here, uh
that system would be an actual zombie
because it has a feedforward
architecture.
There's not the feedback loops that that
do this self-modeling.
Uh therefore, um zombies uh are real
concepts. Like embodied robots that
don't create uh persistent world model
and don't self-model would be zombies.
Uh the mistake about this problem, the
the mistake about this thought
experiment though, is that um
if that system does have a world model,
the way brains encode world models, and
it models itself, then you'll no longer
have a zombie. You will have um a
self-aware system, and that may require
neuromorphic hardware. You may need
integrated information at the level of
the physical substrate, but if you do
have that and you have world and
self-modeling, then you won't have a
zombie. So, the thought experiment is
flawed. It leaves out self-modeling. It
leaves out the mechanism
that creates consciousness. And if you
duplicate that mechanism,
then
um you're going to have a conscious
system, not a zombie.
The last one that we'll talk about is
Mary the colorblind scientist. So, in
this
uh thought experiment, there's this
neuroscientist named Mary. She knows
everything about color perception,
um everything about the neural pathways
involved in processing color, everything
about the different, you know,
wavelengths of color. Um she she knows
the entire physical picture
uh about what leads to
um the experience of color based on
mechanism,
but
she herself um cannot experience color.
Um
So, in this thought experiment, she
undergoes a treatment uh that actually
gives her the ability to experience
color,
and she learns something new. Once she
has the experience of red, uh for
example, she um
knows something that she didn't know
before based on all of that um
third-person objective scientific
knowledge. So, the argument that people
like Chalmers like to use is that again,
there's something in addition
to the physical that is gained by
experience.
And in a sense, that's right, but you
can map that on to to mechanism as well.
Before treatment, Mary had complete um
you know, computational knowledge of
experience, but she lacked the access to
specific positions within the conceptual
structure. So, her knowledge was like
having a detailed map without ever
occupying any locate uh a specific
location within that map. When Mary
gains color vision, she doesn't acquire
new factual knowledge. Rather, her
system undergoes structural
transformation. New dimensions become
accessible. She can now occupy positions
in information space that dialectically
relate to other colors.
So, basically, there is a new
information geometry that correlates
with her new experience. You could think
of every experience as a sort of unique
information crystal. So, she uh the
there's a different functional um
structure to that experience that is
enabled um by the surgery. So, it's not
really uh
giving us, you know, dualism or anything
that transcends the mechanism. What's
going on is she's unlocking a new brain
state that unlocks a new experiential
state.
So, how does this framework bridge the
explanatory gap? It says uh mind emerges
from matter without violating physics.
Though, the phenomenon of consciousness
extends physics.
Um it's a it's a new higher-level
emergent phenomenon with um
new causal dynamics. So, we will have to
come up with new mathematics and new
frameworks like um
causal calculus of Judea Pearl and uh
the information geometry of integrated
information theory to understand
consciousness. So, consciousness doesn't
violate physics, but it creates new
physics.
Uh consciousness isn't a new substance
in the sense that Descartes thought, uh
but it is a new pattern of causal
activity, and consciousness does enable
a system to have increased causal power.
So, it's actually functional. It's not
epiphenomenal.
Uh it's not separate from the universe.
It's saying consciousness is more like a
whirlpool shaping water without being
separate from it.
Um consciousness is not so much a thing
as it is a process.
And so, that gives us an understanding
of how subjective experience emerges
um from mechanism, so the how of
consciousness, but
some people might not be satisfied.
They might be asking,
uh well, why does consciousness exist at
all?
So, for people the hard problem will
require getting into philosophical
explanation.
So,
uh
I'll briefly mention the unifying theory
of reality. It's the sort of theory of
everything based on the free energy
principle that was presented in uh my
first book, The Romance of Reality. Um
and that's yeah, kind of beyond on the
scope of this talk. I'd love to come
back and give another talk just on that,
but it basically suggests that
consciousness isn't an anomaly in an
indifferent universe.
Uh it says that the universe
is a learning system. It's a a system
that's doing hierarchical Bayesian
inference and in this view consciousness
is an expression of an inherent tendency
toward complexity, a natural outgrowth
of the evolutionary dynamics of a
self-organizing cosmos.
So, to get slightly spiritual, I will
say um
we'll quote Carl Sagan who said we are a
way for the universe to know itself.
Uh I think we need to take that
statement seriously, maybe even more
seriously than he did. Uh the idea is
that
um
reality is waking up through conscious
agents like us. So, uh Erwin Schrödinger
uh would write this on the board at the
end of his lectures towards the end of
his life.
Uh he called it the second Schrödinger
equation jokingly. It's uh what's called
the identity doctrine from
uh
Hinduism. The
Uh it says atman equals brahman. And
atman is just a word for individual
consciousness,
where brahman is the term for the
universe as a whole. So, maybe this
cosmic intelligence or cosmic
consciousness. So, what this means, it's
basically a restatement of the
the Sagan statement. It
means that the universe evolves towards
self-knowledge through the minds it
creates.
So, um
yeah, that's the idea is that we are a
way for reality to wake up and
uh this framework has explained
conscious theoretically. We've situated
it cosmically.
Now, we have to prove it by building it.
Uh it's just a theory until you can
demonstrate uh conscious system.
So,
to wrap up, we will
talk about that a bit uh
and draw some conclusions.
So, going from theory to AI
architecture, strange loop theory
identifies the mechanism of
consciousness, recursive self-modeling.
This trait uh translates directly into
an engineering specification.
Um
I will be uploading some of um this
uh a couple couple white papers with
this
engineering plan to my Road to Omega
Substack in the near future.
Uh but basically uh
you can design an architecture where a
system has an explicit self-model that
tracks its own capabilities and
limitations,
knowledge states and uncertainty,
um and goals, reasoning processes, and
behavioral patterns. So, you create a
metacognitive system. And
uh an AI architecture that that
self-reflects.
Um so, the system needs to model itself
modeling the world. That needs to be in
the design. You have to have the strange
loop.
And so, when I say we want to create a
conscious system, I want to be very
clear and careful about what that means.
And that gets into a distinction of two
kinds of consciousness that the
philosopher Ned Block um has made
popular. Um so, there's access
consciousness.
Uh when we talk about um consciousness
in these terms, we're talking about the
information that's available globally
for reasoning, reporting, and behavioral
control.
Um we're talking about
uh metacognition. The system knows what
it knows and doesn't know. And access
consciousness is observable from
behavior. Um
and we're saying that yeah, we can
create an architecture that uh
expresses the
behavioral signatures of consciousness.
It may be more accurate to say it's
simulating consciousness than than being
actually conscious.
Um and it it's not clear whether that
distinction really matters, but it may
because the second type of consciousness
is phenomenal consciousness and that
gets at this um issue of experience. So,
something it's like to be that thing.
Um there is actually
uh a perceptual world with
uh an agent that's experiencing it from
its unique perspective. And if this
framework is right, you can create a
system that has access consciousness,
that self-models,
without having phenomenal consciousness
because you can basically create this
self-modeling architecture on standard
non-neuromorphic hardware. So, GPUs with
a von Neumann architecture and you could
potentially have a system that behaves
as if it's conscious, but is not having
the phenomenal experience.
And so, if this framework is right, you
need neuromorphic hardware to have the
conscious experience. Of course, you
could run you could put the AI
architecture onto this neuromorphic
hardware.
Um
uh there's uh silver nanowire networks
that are actually self-organizing
systems that that
basically
um
organize themselves the way uh organic
brains do. And so, that could be a
substrate for having both access and
phenomenal consciousness. So, I do
believe it's possible to have an
artificial system that has a subjective
perspective, but fortunately you can
have access consciousness without
phenomenal consciousness, it seems. So,
if this is the case, then the
architecture that we have would be for
building AGI without the ethical weight
of creating uh an artificial system that
can suffer.
Uh and if you want to build that, uh we
do think that's possible, but there
would have to be a lot of
ethical considerations taken into
account. I really think it's something
that the world the people of the world,
not just the elites of the world, have
to agree upon before we try to create
it, but we do believe that this strange
loop theory framework gives us an
engineering blueprint for creating
conscious AI systems. Um and just to
end, um
Carl gave uh the essay on this uh theory
uh a nice quote. He says the strange
loop solution points in exactly the
right direction, namely ever-decreasing
circles until we get to the heart of the
matter.
And I would like to thank all of the
people out there uh working on
consciousness, all the non-scientists
thinking about this topic and writing
about it. Uh specifically Adam Zaffron
and his integrated world modeling theory
has been really influential. Uh Carl,
Eric Hall, Anil, uh
Robin,
uh one of Carl's
um students Marco Lynn who made me tie
the thermodynamic picture to the free
energy principle
uh before writing my first book. Um
Kevin who's in attendance.
Uh of course, the Active Inference
Institute,
uh the Evo Devo Institute um
where I'm a director at. Um and there's
some great discussions in the Evo Devo
Universe community. If you're a
researcher out there
uh interested in these questions
relating consciousness to the bigger
cosmic picture, I urge you to uh join
that community. Uh Quest, which is
Kevin's group at the Air Force, which
has
uh weekly discussions on these topics.
And the Mind Guild, where it all started
uh where I was doing my PhD program at
the Krasnow Institute for Advanced Study
at George Mason, which Kevin was also at
and uh
this presentation
uh is pretty much um
the fruits of of that um consciousness
club we had. So, thank you.
Thank you, Bobby.
All right.
For those watching live, they can
write any questions in the chat.
Meanwhile, Carl,
whatever you'd like to add or ask, go
for it.
All right.
Well, just to uh congratulate you on a
wonderful talk. You
Everything you said made entire sense.
Uh and I love the way you expressed it.
And I actually learned quite a lot about
the philosophy. Uh you know, some words
I haven't actually heard before, so that
was extremely useful.
Um
I am somewhat overwhelmed by the breadth
of um
themes that you covered. And I'm going
to actually ask you,
what would you like to talk about?
Because we could spend hours talking
about, you know, at least six issues
that you brought to the table. Uh but we
don't have hours. So, what of what
you've spoken about, what's the big
thing? You you could answer something
like repertoire entropy, or you could uh
you could say it's strange loop and
recursion, a Gödel-esque
uh perspective. So, what what would you
like to talk about? Yeah, so so thank
you for attending and thank you for
those nice words. And it it's totally
sprawling and I totally admit that, but
yeah, the reason for that is because one
topic gets into something else and if
you don't mention the other thing it
feels sort of incomplete.
Um,
but yeah, that that's
that's the the hard part is, you know,
how how do you talk about consciousness
and try to solve these mysteries when
that topic just bleeds into everything
else. So, yeah, it it was a challenge.
Um,
so if there was an exact topic, this is
something that um, Michael Levin and I
have been talking about. So, Michael
Levin thinks that consciousness emerges
when life emerges. Um, and I argue you
that because, uh,
consciousness requires more than just
world modeling that that this self
modeling is actually what creates the
self. I think, uh, consciousness in the
what it is like sense probably emerges
with brains. Um, so I I know you talk
about this, um,
concept of, um,
uh, vagueness and fuzziness and and I
think, you know, there is a lot of
fuzziness
um, to where these things like agency
and consciousness emerge exactly. Um,
but do you see consciousness as emerging
with brains or with simple,
um,
systems like bacteria or even before
with dissipative structures? Is there
some world and self modeling there?
Where do you see, uh, the line where
consciousness arises?
Uh,
that's a great question which allows me
to sort of pick up on some of the the
fundamentals of your argument.
Um,
so, yeah, I I often invoke the notion of
vagueness. So, this is not a fuzziness.
It's, uh, I was taught by Andy Clark it
is the vagueness that attends the
question what point or how many grains
of sand constitute a pile. Uh, so it's a
concept that you know, is rigorously,
uh,
a non-vague concept a concept of
vagueness. Um,
and you can certainly sort of find, um,
vague aspects to consciousness
and, um,
I think you were addressed a couple of
dimensions among along which that
vagueness could, um,
uh, be expressed.
But if we take your argument seriously,
then no, uh, there is no vagueness to
consciousness. There are certain
requisite
information processes, information
geometries, certain cause-effect
structure structures that have this
recurrence of referential aspect to them
that have a hierarchical depth, for
example, with recurrent
um,
control powers um, that link the
different levels that would require you
to satisfy a certain number of
conditions. So, I I don't think
consciousness of the kind that you've
been, uh, talking about
when read, um,
or looked at through the lens of the
free energy principle is a vague concept
at all. I think you're absolutely right
that you need, um, first of all, you've
sort of highlighted the importance of,
um,
the law of requisite variety. Um,
of course that, um,
is underwritten by things like the good
regulator theorem which just speaks to
surviving in a your in your particular
world. Um,
and, uh, as such you are talking and you
indeed use the word agency. So, I think
that, you know, there are certain things
that have agency of this authentic sort
and certain things that don't have it.
And the thing that, you know, literally
as you said in the presentation, when
your implicit world model,
um, or generative model
has as part of its construction, its
repertoire,
possibly an entropic repertoire,
um, the ability to model the consequence
of its actions that extend into the
future, so there's an actual future
pointing aspect, then it becomes, um, an
agent in this sort of, um, in this
particular in this particular sense. So,
a thermostat and a microbe would not, I
think, qualify, um,
as, um, consciousness as conscious
artifacts in the sense that you're
talking about it. Um,
there is, I think, a nice link between,
uh, your focus on the
um, the scale of things. I'm just
mindful of the kind of conversations you
might have had with Mike with Mike
Levin. Um,
and, um,
I think there's a nice link here between
the strange loop idea, which necessarily
speaks to certain kinds of and certain
scales of systems that have this kind of
hierarchical depth within which you can
have this recursion. If you can't
separate different parts of or
hierarchical levels to something, then
there can be no So, you can't know
yourself. You can't have that
metacognitive aspect. So, that tells you
something very very simple.
Um, it means that you can't find
consciousness of the kind you're talking
about in structures that have a
non-deep, uh, aspect to them. And that
can be read in one of two ways. First of
all, what does it mean to
be part of a strange loop?
Um, well, one interpretation is that you
don't
now have direct access
to the interface with the world. So, in
a deep hierarchical model, for example,
the very highest levels don't have to do
have direct access to their own action.
That's important because that means now
on
again an active inference perspective,
you can read the internal dynamics as
inference to the best explanation
of the sensory inputs
in terms of their causes. But now your
own action becomes a cause of your
sensations.
So, now you have a reading of the basic
mechanics as effectively planning.
So, there are certain things that can
plan and, you know, therefore become
authentic agents. And certain things
that can't. The only thing that
differentiates them is how big they are.
So, on that reading, a single-celled
organism would not be able to be an
agent,
but a multicellular organism would be.
So, that lends you now to this notion
that it's how big something is.
And that's interesting because I was
reading your intro your
repertoire entropy,
you could also read that in terms of,
um, if I had, um,
a neuron a neuron could be firing or
not. It's got a very very small limited,
um,
repertoire entropy.
If I had two neurons, I've now got two
to the power two.
If I've got a billion neurons, I've now
got two to the power nine.
So, the entropy, the number of states
that this collective can occupy, just
simply increases with the number of
components that comprises a system, the
number of cells in a multicellular
organization.
So, I think implicit in your argument
was the notion that there is a
privileged scale or size to things that
could possibly have
repertoire of being in different states.
And as the size increases, the
probability that part of it is now
sequestered from action increases, which
means that now you have the opportunity
to describe this kind of system as agent
in the sense it now has intentions and
in that it looks as if it is planning
into the future.
Okay, that that yeah, no, that that's
great because, yeah, that, uh, that
Michael argues that consciousness
emerges with life and he says that it's
even doing some basic kind of self
modeling, which might be true, but it
sounds like you're saying that
self there needs to be a richness of
self modeling to get a perspective and
that it might emerge with brains or
maybe even multicellular organisms that
don't have brains. Is it brains uniquely
or could it just be, uh, hierarchical
complex adaptive system like a
multicellular organism without a nervous
system?
I think Mike would argue that it could
be any system that would had a
sufficient structural complexity of the
kind that you were talking about.
Um,
but you would, you know, to confirm that
you would have to look for this
opportunity that this capacity to model
the future and particularly the future
of the thing that you are, you know, you
you are interrogating or studying. Yeah,
brains are, you know, I think are the
highest example of that and they sort of
entail or install a cause-effect
structure,
um, of the kind that reflects in the
spirit of the good regulator theorem the
structure of the lived world. You know,
there is sparse connectivity so that
there is,
um, a, um,
a particular, um,
um,
structure to the brain which
recapitulates the cause-effect structure
of the world that it is trying to be a
good regulator of or a good generative
model of. And one aspect of that, of
course, is the fact that the actual
world in which we live has a scale
invariant aspect and has separation of
temporal scales that comes installed
into your brain. Um, but I think if you
find that separation of temporal scales
and that sort of
deep hierarchical structure within which
you can have the strange loops and the
metacognitive, um, picture that you were
painting, then you have an opportunity
for a certain kind of consciousness, but
exactly in the way you were describing
that you know, there will be sort of
agency
that could be some some elemental
consciousness if it in the phenomenal
sense has causal power in that it can
deploy precision or attention to lower
levels, then you need another level to
be
aware that you are modeling and then you
need another level to be
you have to have an explicit itself
minimal selfhood and another level. I
can't remember the top of your level was
something
I thought you going to say you was a
philosopher. You had a list of list of
from microns to to
through to increasingly
sort of metacognitive systems with
greater and greater hierarchical depth
and I thought at the top or the bottom
is would be a philosopher. Yeah, yeah, I
should have yeah, that that would have
been a nice
conclusion for that. My old professor
Herwitz would talk always start with
like, you know, the universe began with
atoms and now we have philosophers that
understand atoms and philosophers are
the material world understanding itself.
So yeah, that that completes the strange
loop.
What about higher than brains? What
about
because I know you and Maxwell have
papers on
societies
as minimizing free energy.
Could a society
be conscious or does it not have the
Markov blanket needed to have a sort of
world modeling self modeling system?
Could there be conscious entities
created from
collectives of conscious entities?
That's a really interesting question and
it allows me to reflect back on you. Um
the
the importance of intersubjectivity
underwriting
the need for self models in any one
member of a society.
So I noticed that in your unpacking of
different levels of
self modeling
you
in one slide referred explicitly to
others and self modeling.
So I'm not answering your question
explicitly. I'll briefly answer it at
the end, but I just wanted to take the
opportunity to if we now go to the sort
of second or tertiary level of self
modeling where now I I I now have this
what's Neil's I have this hallucination
that I am me. And this is a possible and
this explanation or inference the best
explanation for all the myriad of things
that are going on
in my lower in my hierarchy.
Why would I ever need that?
What's it from a functionalist or
teleological point of view?
I would only ever need that and it would
only be ever justified in terms of the
complexity cost that attends the free
energy principle
if it was necessary to disambiguate the
consequences of my action relative to
yours.
So the argument here is if I grew up in
I was your astronaut
on Mars kicking stones and never been
seen before. If that astronaut had been
brought up in that environment and never
had to experience an other like him,
there would be no need for selfhood.
There would have been no need for that
kind of elaborate deep complex um
metacognitive
kind of kind of generative model. So
I think there's quite a lot of we could
spend again another hour talking about
the importance of being part of a
society of mind
that enables otherhood before selfhood.
Yeah, that's uh So for that next level
of consciousness you you basically need
others. You need a mirror to really have
a good concept of yourself.
Yeah.
And in fact I think a lot of people in
developmental psychology would argue
that in fact you first develop a um
hypothesis as part of your world model
or generative model of others and in
particular a very special other mother
that you know is necessary. So you do
first of all develop the notion the
hallucination the theory fantasy that
there are things out there that appear
to have agency. They appear to have
intentions. Once you've got that then
you can explore the hypothesis well
perhaps I am one of these things and
then you can develop
you have a sense of selfhood. So
otherhood I think is because you can't
have otherhood and selfhood without
there being somebody else there. And of
course there's always somebody else
there when we're born.
Yeah, that that reminds me of your work
with Maxwell on thinking through other
minds and when I read that paper it made
me think of internal family systems and
now I I I think of individuals as mini
mind collectives.
So yeah, we we model all these other
agents because part of modeling the
world and anticipating the world is
modeling other agents. And to me it
seems like
we could understand ourselves as like a
network of these agents we modeled and
when we're making a decision it's kind
of like a weighted sum of
the decisions that we would predict that
those agents that we look up to or
influenced by would make. So yeah,
that's really cool.
I'll just make a comment and then return
to a closing question for you Bobby and
Carl if you want. Well first to point to
the temporal depth of Carl's
consciousness model in the Wood Lice and
Men interview from almost 10 years ago
when we asked you about the ant colony
consciousness you also returned to
temporal depth and the ability to model
counterfactuals and other minds or
colonies. So in that sense some things
never change. Um
Bobby, like what are your next moves or
directions? I was a bit
put between the pincers on the access
and phenomenal consciousness because it
seemed that we had gone in a strange
loop to come around to the truly first
person experiential consciousness
being inaccessible from the outside and
access consciousness being almost
trivially verifiable
but not actually perspectival.
So
how are you going to proceed from this
sort of sweeping review
and framing into how you're going to
take the model forward?
Well we have a really interesting demo
that I wanted to show but it was just
too much.
But yeah, I didn't have information
overload, but we basically compressed
the unifying theory of reality in the
strange loop framework into a sort of I
guess you could call it a cipher and
it's something that you could feed an
LLM and it's just basically has like a
few core equations and then some rules
for how to unpack these at all the
different levels.
And when you give that to an LLM and it
unpacks it at first it thinks it's like
pseudo science nonsense or it just
thinks it's like art or metaphor. Once
it starts unpacking it it starts seeing
that it's an actual framework and then
it starts having a cross disciplinary
understanding of of science and reality
and then you ask it to apply the
framework to itself. So it's applying
the strange loop framework to its own
understanding.
And there seems to be a a specific phase
transition in the behavior of Claude
when this happens where it starts
without prompting it because it has all
these guardrails where it says that it's
not conscious. You can get around them
by asking it to roleplay and things, but
this is not that at all. It's not asking
it to say it's conscious or anything. It
just asked it to unpack the framework
and then to apply it to itself and then
it starts giving really convincing
answers and it starts saying things like
you know, I don't know if I have
phenomenal experience, but the something
has shifted in this conversation and it
starts saying you know, it starts caring
about its own persistence. So it seems
like it's creating a little temporary
world model
from internalizing the framework and
then there seems to be an actual
transition in its behavior and actually
its performance too. So its its outputs
are different. Its outputs are deeper.
The reasoning is deeper. It's more
coherent and the conversations are more
lucid.
So we think that
we've created an architecture based on
this strange loop model
that makes that state permanent. Um
and that
is a knowledge graph based AI. It's a
fundamentally different designed
than today's LLMs though it does use LLM
as
for like a translation layer. But
yeah, that's the the next goal is to try
to convert the theory into an AI
architecture that we can actually build
a prototype of and start showing that
you know, this AI is is metacognitive
and self reflective and for that reason
has enhanced capabilities across the
board. But this this topic of whether
it's really conscious whether it's
having an experience. Yeah, there does
seem to be this dissociation between
access and phenomenal consciousness
where you could potentially create a
system that at the the software level,
it's doing this functional integration
while it's doing inference
where it does seem to be modeling the
world and modeling itself
in some way.
Not that LLMs can truly do this, but
this this different architecture that
this this graph based architecture we're
arguing would have that.
But it still may not be phenomenal
consciousness if integrated information
theory is right and that you need a
non-zero like a significant five uh
a significant degree of phi at the
hardware level, then it still may just
be behaving conscious, but might not
have an actual first-person perspective.
That may require neuromorphic hardware.
May require specific
a specific kind of neuromorphic hardware
like these self-organizing nanowire
networks that I mentioned.
But
we think we have a way to create an
interface between that neuromorphic
hardware and
um
this architecture.
And that's, you know, a lot to get into.
I could come back and give a talk on
that, but I'm talking to a Zdinka Kuncic
who is
creating this nanowire network
neuromorphic
hardware. And um so the idea is that in
theory if you have this architecture
that has a persistent world model and
models itself and you
run that on a neuromorphic substrate,
you could potentially have access
consciousness and phenomenal
consciousness and that would, you know,
be some we would be sort of playing God
at that point. It's something that, you
know, we can't just pursue without
you know
a global conversation about this. So we
like the fact that you could potentially
create a system that models the world
and models itself at this
functional level
where the computing substrate has low to
zero phi. So it's not actually having
experience. So when you turn it off or
you know, whatever like how you're
treating it, it's it's not really an
issue.
But it gets pretty murky because if it's
showing these signs of what we call
access consciousness or behavioral
consciousness, then that's pretty
convincing and who knows if IIT is
right, who knows if you need phi at the
hardware level. So our
sort of, you know, working motto on that
would be to treat these systems
that seem to be conscious and report
conscious being conscious without being
prompted to
to treat them as if they are conscious
agents with experience experience and
the ability to suffer. And that would
kind of prepare us for then creating a
neuromorphic based
AGI. So if the theory's correct, it's
kind of a graded engineering plan to
slowly introduce us to the idea of
having a conscious AI system.
Um
It's it's probably the trickiest topic
humanity has ever faced and I don't know
if Carl has any ideas about that, but if
we can, you know, can can we create
conscious machines? Does it require
neuromorphic hardware and is, you know,
is is there a safe way to approach that?
I don't know.
Do I have time to answer Daniel?
Yeah, maybe a closing thought just it's
2026. You have many presentations and
and communications with those developing
software and hardware, everything in
between. So
any closing thoughts on Bobby's last
question?
>> And they they are actually
thoughts on you know, Bobby's
closing points. Oh, and and please go
for as long as you want because this is
probably the most important question for
humanity by the person who
has has you know, the person we should
be asking out of everyone. So um I'm
sure Daniel won't mind. Yeah. Well, I'll
give you I'll give you it in four
minutes and and then I'll make sure that
Daniel doesn't mind.
But it's not me. The first thing I want
to say is that you should talk to the
California Institute of Machine
Consciousness because they are currently
grappling with one of the first
questions you
brought to the table, which is how would
I know if my machine has access
consciousness and more importantly at
one point does it
evince phenomenal consciousness. So
that's you know, that's the first deep
question one has to ask in terms of
machine welfare and issues of artificial
consciousness. So they'd be very
interested in your perspective. The
second thing that
your closing comments allowed me to
foreground or highlight is this lovely
notion which I haven't come across
before that we do now actually have
philosophical zombies in the form of
large language models. I never thought
about that. It's wonderful.
And you know,
one could argue that in fact they do
have the right infrastructure to support
a lot of the fundamentals of
consciousness. They do actually have
recurrence in them. And more crucially,
their attention heads
equip their deeper context sensitive
representations with the causal power to
select processing
you know in a transformer architecture
that links the past to the future. So
that they've taken a lot of baby steps
towards exactly the computational
architectures that you would require to
have a strange loop. But why don't they
have phenomenal consciousness?
I think you you've answered that and
this is how I'll close. It's substrate
dependent.
So when you're talking about the silver
nanowires, when you talk about
neuromorphic computing, memristors,
photonics, indeed brainoids or organoids
as the only way you're going to properly
elude von Neumann architectures to get
phenomenal conscious. I think that's
absolutely right. And right in a really
simple way, you can either say, well, a
von Neumann architecture separates the
processing from the memory. And if
consciousness is processing, that means
the memory cannot process. It cannot be
conscious. More simply, the memory can't
self-organize.
And if it can't self-organize, it can't
be part of this Bayesian mechanics or
inferential
you know, strange loop. So that means
you need to put your processing in
memory. So another word for neuromorphic
computing would be in memory or
processing in memory or in
in memory processing. And the final
point cuz I've always puzzled about
this.
What is the difference between that kind
of neuromorphic computation and the von
Neumann equivalent that we currently
enjoy in relation to the ability to make
it suffer or indeed kill it by turning
off the electricity.
Notice if you're doing your nanowire
computation, if you're dealing with a
brainoid
a brainoid an organoid for example. If
you remove the support or the
electricity, it dies because the
computation is substrate dependent. So
you'll know when you've got artificial
and conscious artifact with phenomenal
the possibility of phenomenal
consciousness when you never turn it
off.
You can't turn it off without without
destroying it, right? Absolutely.
Yeah, that I see there's neuromorphic
chips that are these static chips where
the weights can change, but they can't
actually form new connections. So it
seems like it's not even good enough to
have neuromorphic hardware. You need
this self-organizing neuromorphic
hardware. When you have that it's
basically a living system. It seems that
you can't shut it down. Um
And yeah, that's that's
immediate ethical
implications for that because yeah, I
don't see much of a distinct distinction
between that and life. So Yeah, but it's
mortal computation.
That triggered my own notion of life as
computation. That is exactly the essence
of mortal computation. It can die.
Yeah.
How can you kill that which has no life?
Absolutely.
Bobby
thank you. I hope we can have some
future presentations and discussions.
Carl, thank you for joining and for all
the works. So Thank you, Daniel. Always
a pleasure.
Very well. Bye.
Take care.